at 120 in the morning on october seventh
I was fast asleep the phone rang i'm not
sure i heard it my wife yelled out this
is it so i stumbled out of bed still
half-asleep got to the phone and i think
i was trembling at this point but I
pretty sure I knew what it was and I was
greeted by a nice swedish accent on the
other side Goran hansen at that point i
think i said oh my god and then then he
reassured me that after congratulating
me that it was not a hoax and then ice
in my mind the fog lifted him so I
decided what I how I had to proceed for
the next hour or so before the press
conference and I first person I call was
my father 86 year old father who's been
the hopeful for years about this so he
was ecstatic i called my kids I called
my best friend then I called the press
officer at Berkeley because i was born
years ago that i had to do this and as a
result there were two press officers in
my home at two thirty in the morning
lining up the TV camera crews and since
then my life has not been the same